do you guys think that sex work is
immoral yeah I don't an only fan but it
wasn't like Gina fils it was lingerie
yeah Bo whatever I done it and when I
finished it I felt very degraded I felt
very like why did I actually do that now
I know there's girls out there who do
that they don't feel that way that is
perfectly fine you do you you feel the
way you feel but me personally like like
in the future how like when I have kids
all in the future and if my kids found
out about that they'll probably get
bullied in school they people be like oh
you're M doing this your man do that and
your man as well he's not going to if
you don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not a there's not a high
respect for yourself why expect that
from others then